what I would Monday night is
over between the bears and
the Steelers Chris that means we
are exactly halfway through
the season
Argus faster I'll go back yes
that's we're almost half of
the season right or get getting
as a good time
to head out to mid season awards
individuals on the field some
coaches as well
some rookies so let's start with
the M. V. P. N. this is
an interesting choice yeah
tonight %HESITATION but
according to points
Tom Brady is the favorite Josh
Allen added some days just
behind calibrated play today
Stafford was off about him in a
moment that Prescott it was not
a good thing to be on this list
now they're kind of
to death row right there I
definitely did I mean
Josh Allen Murray Prescott
nothing good Stafford is my pick
to win the MVP but of course yes
it was not a good night
I know that but again
I'm not going to just make a
reaction off of one game he's
been phenomenal throughout the
whole year he's made the rams
a different football team all
together because it doesn't
have to just be about
one in the
legs I don't didn't look like
that way against the Tennessee
Titans and I'd
touchdown to interception ratio
is about as good as anybody in
football quarterback ratings
have been as good as anybody in
football he's still makes a ton
of plays a big throws in
the pocket I mean
did did we think
that everybody just think the
rams are gonna be seven and two
and have this type office of
Matthew Stafford I remember
hearing a lot of people like
well now we'll see what
staffers all about I don't want
it right away that well yeah
it's exciting you are given that
yes I was excited for it
I think it came you know came to
life even faster than
I expected and again I know
tonight was struggles bill for
for Matthew Stafford he did some
dumb stuff tonight there's
no doubt about that
but for the season he's been
pretty on point I'm gonna guess
that we're gonna see what he
said after the game that he
had pretty good accountability
for what happened with
the %HESITATION usually does
areas
those
two turnovers yeah I mean the
first one %HESITATION
you know guys got hold me I
gotta do a better job just
by just falling on that one
or %HESITATION you know thrown
over Roberts said maybe earlier
%HESITATION was trying to maybe
get back through it but
%HESITATION can't have that I
basically spot on fourteen
points I mean can't do that me
and I felt so she gets a good
team like that they want to you
know get out front run
the football mix coverages do
all that kind of stuff so
%HESITATION just wasn't good
enough early in the game turn
our turnovers really you know
killed us and those around me
so %HESITATION you know if I
clean those up and I know it
will
take a lot of confidence in this
team to go out there and
and play some you know really
good football our defense
really good you know good enough
to keep us in the game
you know Sir really you know if
we don't turn the ball over
twice
%HESITATION you know give us a
chance to win that one so
%HESITATION got to play better
myself %HESITATION you know
first and foremost
with the way the Tennessee
defense played tonight against
Matthew Stafford I was reminded
that the same group that caps
Patrick Mahomes only three
points here Russell right
they've got some things figured
out they do they're good up
front their creative coach Dave
game plan specific defensive
schemes in a week
to week basis one we cover four
might look like this the next
week cover for looks a little
different you know that's where
they're special
and Paul I know you and I've
talked about a little bit you
know during our podcast sessions
together that
they're one of the best zone
defenses in football they
really understand how to pass
people off from one area to
the next and that led to a lot
of Stafford struggles and I get
some dumb decisions but
certainly let's give credit to
the Titans defense to
absolutely from a team defense
playing extremely well let's go
down to individual defenders
time to pick a defensive MVP at
the halfway point of the year
Myles Garrett the favorite
DJ wanted Pittsburgh right
behind him
and Ramsey
is your pick coming off his mind
it might get by I'm going
with chalk here I mean I think
it's Myles Garrett to me Myles
Garrett in the best defensive
player in football this year
you know he's very good against
the run
but you could see
one on one around the edge
I mean he's he's reached the
Aaron Donald status of Elvis on
black available these one on one
you have to have a plan for
Myles Garrett he's just too big
he's too fast
he disruptive we saw that again
today
the bangles so it's the first
time in a while I think we got
to this point of the year
arriving at die or dollars
definitely the
defense of the pay always godly
somebody challenging a little
bit higher and yeah I go and
Myles Garrett for sure we spend
so much time in the spring
talking about the rookies to
being getting to know them
I'm glad that we're going with
rookies of the year as well
%HESITATION at our halfway point
of the season picks
so are we beginning with the
offense or the defense how bout
with you there on the left side
we have offense jamarr chase
way out in front and on defense
Michael Parsons even further
out in front of that so the
defense is a no brainer it's
not even a discussion I don't
think I mean
Michael Parsons is definitely
the defense a rookie of
the year Michael Parsons is
already one of the best
linebackers in
full
I mean he's one of the best even
the players in the league
we can do everything rush the
passer defense and cover
linebackers are
running backs out of the
backfield
will fill the gap and take on a
full back get a ball field at
the tailback there's nothing you
can do
I mean I'm being human being but
and credibly athletic and
you could see how we could
change the fall down
and then fall did you say chase
just to get
it's one I mean I'm going to
chase just because %HESITATION
I did not not that smart to take
myself there like that put
your more chase
for what he has done this year I
mean he's been arguably
the most explosive wide receiver
in football made a few mistakes
today I know that
but then what one
week after week jamarr chase has
been amazing I want to give
back Johnson love not G. Harris
of course been good for
the Steelers
but nobody's made the impact for
their offense as a rookie
like jamarr chase I remember
that big discussion should they
go with the wide receiver or
should they go with the offense
and adult life halfway through
the season they certainly made
did right right six of that here
I think you have a lot of
good choices for coach of the
year and I'm curious to find
out which one do you think is
best Kingsbury
at the top John Harbaugh always
does a good job my Frankel will
has been excellent
Sean Payton soup
and ran Staley's first year
with the Chargers
a lot of guys to pick from right
there
one guy which was on that list
too was back on the floor
I mean how many years in a row
to the taxes have to be good
and he has to manage like
dysfunctional situations before
he gets a block here
Kingsbury here's well and trust
me everybody
sixty four I pick these
activities first all right
we've talked before the year
this is a hot seat here they
had to do something they had to
get
yeah they have a good roster
built by Steve Kerr
Kingsbury has
play caller I think he's
understand how to manage
the game a little bit even if
they don't get big plays
you know we've talked about a
certain weeks where they can be
patient and go on fifteen play
yard fifteen play drives so
I give cooking's very with a lot
of pressure on him a lot of
credit for what he did Dan
this like that right that's nice
right
it's a great looking lineup
and I want to say one more thing
about Kliff Kingsbury you
just say one more thing
we were talking before the
season started about how much
you like Kyler Murray but you
needed cliff Kingsbury to do
a little more to help him
exactly right at our spots yes
what is
he done in cold recorded it
today too right what is he done
that to kind of answer that
because I think it's more
formation usage is not just for
wide receivers and Kyler Murray
in the shock on play after play
you know we talk about that
a lot last year was very easy to
break them down I think
as the season went on
you know they gotten better on
the offense a line which is
allowed Kliff Kingsbury company
be more physical stay true to
the running game all you wanna
play pass even to stop caller
very
fine here chase admins here's
James o'connor
and then you know and then the
ability to
win teams took away the big
plays
of Kingsbury's had an inventory
of offense
and ways to find five yard
completion six your completion
eight your completion so that's
what I really love and that's
what I meant about helping Kyler
Murray out
and we've seen Kyler Murray of
course play better football
because I think he's got a few
more advantages schematically
now yeah not just a little bit
better he's played a whole lot
better no doubt things very calm
again that way
we invite you to download that
points bad app and get better
odds daily promotions and
betting options you won't find
anywhere else points better live
your best life